[Applaudissements]
j'ai 15 ans
la nuit parfois j'essaie de m'endormir
et je n'y arrive pas j'ai l'impression
qu'on ne me dit pas tout
mes parents commencent à se positionner
sur le monde par l'alimentation dans un
premier temps il remplace les céréales
les céréales multicolores par du pain
complet d'une boulangerie artisanale
avec mon frère en entreprend une
rébellion on tient un matin
j'ai 17 ans tout a changé c'est la
première marche pour le climat mes
parents signent mon journal de classe
pour que je rejoigne la manifestation
ça m'impressionne je vais à Bruxelles je
prends le train avec quelques copines
c'est la première fois que je vais
manifester
je ne sais pas encore je ne sais pas
encore vraiment dire pourquoi je n'ai
pas les bons mots mais je sais que je ne
suis pas d'accord et que la nuit je dors
mal
les mois passent c'est de plus en plus
dur tous les jeudis j'en apprends plus
peut-être pour mon âge
les affiches parlent d'eau qui monte et
des températures qui augmentent je me
rends compte que mon futur va être
vraiment compliqué si pas impossible
je ne sais pas que de l'autre côté du
monde on meurt déjà pour des modes de
consommation que nos pays occidentaux
ont choisi d'adopter
parfois je ne veux plus aller marcher
j'ai 18 ans et un deuxième hiver arrive
ça fait un an que je marche dans la rue
pour des changements en faveur de la
crise climatique ça ne m'amuse plus du
tout
l'école essaye de nous retenir sur ses
bancs mes parents aimeraient que je
réussisse mes mathématiques il pleut
presque tous les jeudis
alors j'organise les marches je suis
dans la team nationale avec des amis qui
me sont chers
nous sommes une équipe majoritairement
féminine bilingue classe moyenne riche
presque toute blanche il y a une fille
qui me plaît dans le groupe
j'ai 18 ans et sortir dans la rue me
donne envie de crier chaque jeudi depuis
plus d'un an je fais une pancarte et sur
celle-ci cette fois j'ai noté
laissez-moi vivre encore
j'ai 18 ans et j'ai vraiment envie de
vivre j'ai l'impression que je vais
mourir trop tôt et que ce ne sera pas de
ma faute j'ai l'impression que je vais
mourir en ayant mal
j'ai un peu de colère dans mon ventre ou
de la peur je ne sais jamais je m'en
fiche d'apprendre les mathématiques
Adélaïde me parle de ses amis au Vietnam
chez elle et eux la nature s'énerve leur
maison sinon
chez nous on crie dans la rue de 14 à
16h question de privilège
internet me montre des images terribles
des ours blanc qui deviennent jaunes des
noms d'espèces qui disparaissent qu'on
fait disparaître et d'autres enfermés
dans des cages vendus contre un ticket
pour le zoo
il y a ces grands incendies dont les
flammes paraissent être inventées tant
elles sont grandes les images fusent
parfois il y en a tellement que j'ai
l'impression qu'elles sont irréelles
j'ai 18 ans je suis dans mon lit je ne
sais plus comment dormir
alors je suis invitée dans des grands
événements on mettant le micro je sais
dire distinctement de quoi j'ai peur
j'ai peur de l'augmentation de la
température de la fonte des glaciers
j'ai peur pour toutes celles et ceux qui
perdent leur maison parfois leur vie
dans les cœurs séquences du
réchauffement climatique
je vais à la Coop 25 à Madrid une grande
conférence dans laquelle 196 pays
participent les pays signataires de la
convention cadre des Nations Unies sur
les changements climatiques
j'ai 18 ans et je pense qu'on va changer
le monde je pense qu'il y aller va
régler tous nos problèmes ou du moins
engendrer beaucoup de solutions et je
pense que nos politiques vont prendre
leur responsabilité
je vais à Madrid en bus ça me prend 33
heures je loupe mes examens pour m'y
rendre avant d'y aller je suis tellement
stressée que je fais des crises
nerveuses où je perds connaissance et
j'argumente devant mon directeur
pourquoi y aller à plus de sens que mes
50% en mathématiques
33 heures de bus une heure en avion les
dirigeants viennent du même pays mais ne
font pas la même route dans ma tête tout
bas je pense c'est donc ça les
changements qui veulent nous voir
adopter
les politiques nous disent de faire
attention de prendre le train le bus de
repenser nos déplacement on appelle le
citoyen à être responsable
six mois après la Coop je lis dans un
journal que la ministre belge de la
mobilité a pris l'avion entre Anvers et
Bruxelles
c'est 55 km
je repense à mes 33 heures de trajet
j'ai envie de pleurer je suis en colère
je rencontre des activistes des quatre
coins du monde et le soir entre mes amis
qu'il est larmes aux yeux je veux vivre
dans la comme je chante une chanson en
tenant les mains d'un garçon de 16 ans
quand je lui demande c'est quoi le
réchauffement climatique pour toi il me
répond ça veut dire que les anciens de
mon village vont pêcher le saumon et
rentre les mains vides
il s'endort en ayant mal au ventre il a
faim
ce soir-là Madrid est grand et froid je
rentre le corps lourd chez moi mes
parents cuisinent souvent du saumon et
tout autre sorte de poisson d'ailleurs
je pense à lui dans deux semaines on ne
se verra plus et je mange à une grande
table dans un restaurant de Madrid dans
un restaurant vegan où on ne mange pas
de poisson par choix politique
ce soir là je n'ai presque pas faim et
en débrief de notre journée
j'ai 18 ans et autour de la table je
parle d'une possible fin du monde
j'ai 21 ans j'ai rejoint des mouvements
plus radicaux ceux dont les médias ne
parlent en fait presque jamais
la Coop et puis les quelques marches
pour le climat auquel j'ai participé ne
font plus sens pour moi
mais je continue de me battre
parce que quand je pense à mon futur le
mot me battre me semble le plus
approprié
mais alors si les marches pour le climat
ne répondent plus à mes attentes où
puis-je trouver des gens qui comme moi
ont besoin de faire quelque chose
le 26 octobre 2019 des militants
militantes écologistes et des riverains
ont ouvert une occupation sur le site
d'une ancienne sablière à Arlon en
Belgique une Z de l'acronyme zone à
défendre
détruire une forêt en 2022 quand on a lu
les rapports des scientifiques on ne
peut que comprendre que c'est dangereux
alors certains choisissent d'y vivre
quand elles sont menacées de
déforestation comme Arlon ou comme un
autre Dame des Landes des années
auparavant
c'est un mode de lutte qui n'implique
pas que des fois institutionnelles ou
des pétitions des manifestations
organisées ou des partages sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est de l'action directe on se lève et
on se bouge
habiter devient résister
alors vu de l'extérieur certains
citoyens imaginent les hadistes qui
occupent la Z comme des personnes
marginales des junkies des pourvu de
toute attache
j'ai souvent entendu de la part de
personnes qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
cette forme de lutte que les activistes
sur les aident ne travaillent pas
profitent du terrain de la société en
s'installant sur une zone
mais il est elle ne sont pas là par
plaisir
yels sont là par nécessité
c'est se mettre en danger son corps sa
vie en général c'est mettre en danger
son avenir parce que les retombées
juridiques sont lourdes et effrayantes
c'est une prise de risque que de
défendre un bois ça a l'air bête dit
comme ça quand j'ai compris que je
risquais mon casier judiciaire pour
défendre une forêt ça m'a pris à la
gorge
dans quel monde voulons-nous exister
pour certains
occupé et faire vivre une Zade est une
prise de risque nécessaire face à
l'angoisse du monde
j'ai rejoint la ZAD Darlan après avoir
perdu le sens dans les marches pour le
climat j'ai trouvé des gens qui me
ressemblent qui se bougent qui veulent
vivre encore
la Z comment refuge comment liens en ce
que nous entre ce que nous voulions
faire et ce que nous pouvions faire
Arlon a été pour moi à l'ouverture un
champ des possibles énormes je ne suis
pas la seule à mal dormir et je ne suis
pas la seule à avoir besoin de concret
dans ma lutte
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de plus fort que de
mettre son corps en mouvement en danger
pour défendre un bois
Arlon un jour j'ai dû surveiller une
route avec des jumelles j'étais en
binôme avec un garçon qui est devenu un
ami on surveillait la route parce qu'on
avait peur que la police vienne nous
expulser j'étais assise contre un arbre
et toutes les 10 minutes je faisais un
signe de la main c'est bon tout va bien
il n'y a personne
la police parfois installe des barrages
autour des routes de la forêt il y a une
angoisse quasi permanente d'être
surveillée
je n'ai jamais eu peur tout en étant
aussi convaincu d'être au bon endroit
alors je n'ai pas été beaucoup là-bas
entre les études les copains les projets
surveiller un bois ne semblait pas tâche
facile
j'admire les gens qui ont passé l'hiver
il y a quelque chose de l'ordre
d'encourage immense que d'oser laisser
sa vie pour défendre un bois
j'aimerais tant citer tous les noms
toutes les blessures et joie que la
lutte nous tatoue sur le corps
j'aimerais citer tous ces moments de
joie intense autour du feu ah osé
espérer qu'un jour la vie soit enfin
douce
les aides sont une réponse parmi
d'autres face à l'angoisse d'un monde
qui s'écroule les scientifiques nous
parlent de trois ans et puis ce sera
trop tard les existences seront
déclenchées un point de non retour alors
il est temps de sérieusement s'activer
j'ai 21 ans et je ne sais même pas
jusque quand je pourrais vivre et avoir
le temps de me le demander et clairement
un être privilège
je ne peux pas vivre comme si je ne
savais pas je sais je sais pourquoi je
lutte et quels sont les dangers je sais
que si la température mondiale continue
d'augmenter on va connaître des
inondations des pluies intenses des
vagues de chaleur et des incendies de
plus en plus fort de plus en plus
fréquents
je sais que l'augmentation est beaucoup
plus rapide que ce que les scientifiques
prévoyaient et c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est pas mes angoisses qui grandissent
dans mon ventre qui crée ces histoires
ce sont les spécialistes les
scientifiques dans le dernier rapport du
GIEC je l'ai lu en entier c'est
indigeste ça m'a donné envie de tout
brûler
parce que je suis morte de peur plus
j'en apprends plus j'ai peur
alors oui on vous le dit sous toutes ses
formes c'est une urgence une copine
activiste écrivait dans une vidéo nous
sommes la première génération à vivre
les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique et la dernière à pouvoir y
faire quelque chose
j'ai essayé de vous le dire sans
violence j'ai essayé d'utiliser les
pancartes j'ai pris le micro on me l'a
donné d'ailleurs quand je souriais dans
la rue vous m'avez tendu le micro avant
que mon discours dérange
en 2019 j'aurais aimé que tout se règle
avec ma pancarte j'aurais aimé que nos
politiques nous entendent j'aurais aimé
à 17 ans pouvoir assister à mes cours de
mathématiques réussir mon année
brillamment me concentrer sur mes
problèmes personnels et évoluer avec des
proches qui n’angoisse pas d'une planète
qui s'effrite
j'étais naïve avec ma pancarte de croire
qu'il ne nous laisserait vivre
je suis née blanche
issue de la classe moyenne je suis une
privilégiée
ça m'a aidé à pouvoir organiser ces
marches ça m'a aidé à ne pas avoir peur
de la police dans des actions de
désobéissance civile
alors sans vouloir et puis leguer sur la
question des privilèges et des miens en
l'occurrence j'ai conscience d'être la
matérialisation de l'écologie
bien-pensante et socialement acceptée de
notre époque
toute la réflexion que j'ai apporté
aujourd'hui est le résultat d'un travail
sur ce que je connais en Belgique et
tout près mais mon discours ne peut pas
s'adapter à toutes les formes de lutte
par-delà les frontières
alors à 21 ans je continue de lutter
avec des mouvements radicaux parce qu'il
nous restait trois ans en avril 2017
d'après les rapports du GIEC pour
maintenir la terre viable
nous sommes en avril 2022 quand on
m'appelle pour écrire cet EDX 5 ans ce
sont les coulets
nous sommes au-delà du laps de temps que
le GIEC nous avait laissé les
catastrophes naturelles s'amplifient
on ne peut plus fermer les yeux c'est
devenu criminel de faire semblant
alors alors
osons espérer la vie d'une façon
respectueuse pour la terre et tous ses
habitants habitants
changer et espérer un autre monde n'est
pas une tâche facile mais la vie mérite
que nous nous battions pour elle
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]